[Música]
Hola soy Marina sardiña y les doy la
bienvenida a Expreso de oriente El
magacín quincenal de France 24 en el que
les acercamos las noticias de Medio
Oriente América Latina Esto es lo que
veremos en el programa de hoy en Israel
continúan las protestas contra las
reformas propuestas por el recién
formado gobierno israelí de Benjamín
netanyahu y sus socios
ultraconservadores y ultraderechistas
que buscan revisar el sistema jurídico
del país y debilitar el tribunal supremo
además de impulsar la agenda de Los
Socios de gobierno de extrema derecha el
presidente Turco allí perdogan insinuó
que podría adelantar las elecciones un
mes que se celebrarán este año en
Turquía la votación se considera la más
importante en generaciones erdoan se
enfrenta a su prueba más dura para
perpetuar su gobierno de 20 años en
medio de una inflación récord
exhausto en la cruz es el título del
nuevo poemario del poeta palestino
nachoan darwis un título que condensa el
hastío de un pueblo sometido a durante
siglos a la violencia donde se mezcla
además el deseo el amor y la nostalgia
iniciamos en Israel porque a menos de un
mes de la formación de gobierno de
coalición liderada por el Primer
Ministro israelí Benjamín netanyahu la
ciudadanía continúa saliendo a las
calles en contra de las reformas
judiciales que permitirían al parlamento
limitar el poder de la Corte Suprema lo
que para muchos supone un ataque a la
democracia de tanyagua asumía el cargo
el pasado 29 de diciembre y gobierna en
coalición con la ultraderecha de
bengavir quien también plantea reformas
para anexar la cisjordania ocupada y
silenciar aún más la causa Palestina
veamos la siguiente historia
pocas semanas después de asumir el cargo
el Primer Ministro Israel y Benjamín
netanyahu enfrenta una oleada de
protestas con miles de personas saliendo
a las calles en contra de las reformas
propuestas por su coalición de gobierno
el más conservador de la historia los
planes del gabinete de netanyahu pasan
por cambiar el sistema judicial
debilitando así a la Corte Suprema o la
anexión de Jordania ocupada para muchos
israelíes esto atenta contra la
democracia del país
estamos aquí en la generación joven del
país estamos aquí para gritar que no
vamos a dejar que esto ocurra vamos a
estar en las calles en las casas de los
políticos de la kinesia en el parlamento
en el Ministerio de Justicia vamos a
protestar no vamos a permitir que Israel
se convierta en una dictadura
creo que el gobierno israelí debería
entender que no tiene un mandato para
destruir la democracia israelí que el
hecho de que estén intentando destruir
los controles y equilibrios de la
Democracia israelí no funcionará
lucharemos hasta el último minuto para
defender nuestra democracia
[Música]
el polémico plan para cambiar el poder
judicial limitaría la capacidad de la
Corte Suprema para derogar leyes además
el gobierno tendría un papel más
importante en el nombramiento de jueces
otra de las reformas aclamadas por el
ala ultraderechista del gobierno cuyo
líder es bengavir es la prohibición de
banderas palestinas en espacios públicos
para las organizaciones humanitarias
esto es un intento más por silenciar a
los palestinos junto a estas polémicas
un fallo del tribunal supremo prohibió
que el Aliado de netanyahu ayer y se
desempeñe como ministro por una
condenada anterior de fraude fiscal si
no se despide arggeri el gobierno de
Israel está violando la ley Un gobierno
que no obedece la ley es un gobierno
ilegal ya no puede exigir a los que
obedezca la ley sino despide argelery
Israel entrará en una crisis
constitucional sin precedentes y dejará
de ser una democracia y no será un
estado respetuoso de la ley
una situación que Aviva más las
tensiones entre El Ejecutivo y la Corte
Suprema y pone contra las cuerdas a
netanyahu y sus socios Ultra ortodoxos y
de extrema derecha
y en Turquía el presidente reyeta y
perdogan prepara el terreno para las
elecciones presidenciales y
parlamentarias que se celebrarán el
próximo 18 de junio pero el mandatario
quien pretende extender su gobierno de
dos décadas coquetea con la posibilidad
de adelantar los comicios al 14 de mayo
erdoan se enfrenta la prueba más dura en
años con un índice de popularidad
mermado debido a la crisis económica y
una oposición fracturada sin tener un
rival claro la nueva fecha propuesta por
el mandatario tiene una fuerte carga
simbólica ese día de 1950 se celebraron
las primeras elecciones democráticas en
Turquía Esto es lo que dijo
el 14 de mayo de 1950 el difunto
menderes entró en los corazones de la
nación diciendo Basta ya la nación tiene
la palabra y salió de las urnas con una
victoria aplastante
después de 73 años una vez más en el
mismo día nuestra nación volverá a decir
basta a estos golpistas a estos
codiciosos incompetentes a estos
entusiastas de la colonia que corren
contra nosotros llamándose a sí mismos
la mesa de los seis
exhausto en la cruz es el título del
nuevo poemario del poeta palestino Nach
One darwins un título que condensa el
hastío de un pueblo sometido durante
siglos a la violencia y una visión de la
realidad y cotidianidad que atraviesa al
pueblo palestino donde se mezcla además
el deseo el amor y la nostalgia darwins
ha publicado nueve libros de poesía en
árabe y su obra ha sido traducida a más
de 20 idiomas nuestra cronista cultura
lea yuguel habló con darwins en la
pasada edición de la feria del libro de
Guadalajara México veamos la entrevista
Gracias por compartir este momento con
nosotros en France 24 yourshare you Last
wish
compartes tu apellido darwich con otro
poeta palestino muy famoso más es un
artista que te inspiró y en general
Quiénes son los artistas escritores que
te dieron ganas de escribir One
[Música]
es una lista incontable es una lista
enorme desde la antigüedad hasta esta
mañana así que es difícil decir nombres
porque son como cientos de miles de
nombres e incluso más
publicaste 9 libros de poesía en árabe y
ha sido traducido a más de 20 idiomas
aquí en la feria del libro de
Guadalajara presentas la versión en
español de exhausto en la cruz Por qué
elegiste este poema entre los demás para
titularlo
porque representa mucho al libro el
contenido del libro expresa esta
situación estar exhausto en una cruz
porque normalmente cuando te crucifican
vas a morir y a descansar pero en
nuestro caso como pueblo palestino que
vamos ya más décadas en la cruz me
refiero a la cruz de la ocupación y el
exilio todas las circunstancias que lo
rodean
[Música]
este libro como tu obra en general Está
marcado por el territorio el paisaje la
tierra y claro parece lógico ya que tu
vida como palestino no puede separarse
de los conflictos de la tierra pero
también he sentido leyendo este libro
que el mar está muy presente puedes
contarme algo más sobre tu relación con
este elemento
el mar es un tema complicado en
Palestina
porque es una puerta al mundo pero
también fue la puerta de los ocupantes a
lo largo de la historia Cuando Estoy
junto al mediterráneo en Palestina
siento que el mar también está ocupado
no siento que el mar sea una
Tierra Libre
que el mar sea lo que debería ser mar
significa apertura y carecemos de
apertura al mar debido a la continua
ocupación y además la mayoría de nuestra
población en Palestina no puede ir al
mar porque los israelíes les impiden
llegar al mar
yo sí puedo ir Pero sigo teniendo este
sentimiento sobre otros que no pueden
llegar al
margen escribir es a la vez una forma de
difundir de compartir información con el
resto del mundo y dejar huellas
recuerdos para el futuro y esos son
precisamente los retos a los que se
enfrenta cada día el pueblo palestino
más que otros países cómo te sientes
ante estos retos cada día como palestino
como periodista y como artista
dos cosas como Ciudadano palestino todo
esto está mi cuerpo lo siento todos los
días lo respiro todos los días
y cuando se trata de poesía
otra cosa la poesía no consiste en dar
información la información está
disponible para todos en todos los
medios de comunicación pero parece que
al mundo no le importa mucho esta
información con mis escritos no intento
convencer a nadie de nada si alguien
leyera mi obra sabría no diría la verdad
Pero sabría que es un testimonio de mi
vida personal y se supone que es también
un testimonio sobre la experiencia de mi
pueblo
[Música]
no es tu primera vez en Latinoamérica ya
has visitado México Colombia y ahora has
pasado unos días en el corazón del mundo
de la literatura latina aquí en la feria
del libro de Guadalajara que se levantó
más grande e importante de todo el
continente y tal y como se está
mostrando en esta edición con poemas
tanto en árabe como en español que
parecen hechos con la misma monja de
tinta conectas con los poetas de este
continente ves similitudes con las
luchas y problemas de esos países
[Música]
no solo con pertenezco a este continente
pertenezco a las luchas del pueblo
latinoamericano en general
las cuestiones de Justicia social de
liberación todas ellas están dentro de
mis sentimientos y de mis pensamientos y
al mismo tiempo adoro la poesía
latinoamericana creo que es
probablemente la mejor poesía que se
escribe ahora en el mundo
[Música]
una edición bilingüe en la que los
textos están en árabe y también su
traducción en español y precisamente con
la lectura de dámela uno de los poemas
más desgarradores del libro Nos
despedimos de esta edición de Expreso de
oriente gracias por acompañarnos hija